I think anytime a person comes out it
displays someone's courage and bravery
the difficulty to stand up in front of
God and everybody in your community and
your religion and your friends and your
family and your everybody and say I'm
sorry this is my truth I'm not like you
with the fear of rejection on all fronts
it's remarkable and terrifying and so do
I think it helped yes I think it helped
tremendously I think he was inordinately
brave but he was about to be outed and
he called him he said this is going to
happen and so he knew herb very well and
so herb really talked him through it and
I said I think this is what will help
you and he listened and he did it and
because the it was one of the I I don't
know whether it was the inquire of the
star I don't I don't remember but they
said they were going to out him and
which was rather generous of them to say
we're going to do this story do you want
to comment on it first and and herb and
I both said to him you you should do
this this will make it much easier on
you and it gave him the kind of freedom
that he didn't have before so yes I
think it's I think it's very very
important that a person live their truth
and be who they - who they are do I
think it's incumbent upon anyone to out
anyone or for anybody - must they come
out I think that's a personal choice I
would never
push anyone to do that I would encourage
someone to do that I would support them
in doing that sometimes you know I can't
make it a rule I think it's a principle
more than a rule to me sometimes there
are situations where there are people
who are doing terrible things to this
community and they are closeted and it's
important to talk about that and I don't
quite know how you do that in a way that
really makes a difference without
getting your fingers into their business
but I have to say that sometimes when
that happens I have to say that I have
been delighted
they have done the most extraordinary
job in making the LGBT issues mainstream
and what's so valuable about that I
think is that in the very beginning of
the movement there were no role models
for anyone
people didn't know that they could
connect to other gay people there were
there was nobody out there for them so
what David Cohen and max Mutchnick did
when they created Will & Grace was they
gave it a face they gave it a name they
gave it a place in history they gave it
a way for that young gay person in
nowhere USA to say there's somebody out
there like me and I don't have to feel
bad about myself
I'm on television and that changed the
world
I do not know who the first person was
that came out to me I've been surrounded
by gay people all of my life I went to a
performing arts camp in New Hope
Pennsylvania and anybody who's you know
in the gay community knows Pennsylvania
in Bucks County it's like I it was a
performing arts camp and everybody came
there from the summer from New York so I
mean I just knew that everybody was gay
I had one good friend who was in
Repertory Theater with me and he a
ganache I mean I remember him agonizing
about coming out to me I had somebody
else in in college come out to me
also a very agonizing painful expression
of their of who they were and fear and
terror that I would reject them and in
both cases I already knew that they were
gay
it wasn't it wasn't just my
understanding of LGBT issues it was my
understanding of human issues it was
like I had been you know that little
girl who was you know the star of the
high school play and the junior high
school that I you know I had been the
outsider ayah was the other I was the
different one and I understood it I
didn't and so because I was around gay
people and they were my friends they
weren't they
I mean there were these dancers and that
at this performing arts camp in the
summer that they looked out for me I was
really really young and they they
protected me I I they were my family I
it was as though I grew up in that not
anywhere else so it it all I knew was
that it they were my family and they
protected me and they changed my life
and I they were my friends and I wanted
to be connected with them forever and
when things were not going well for them
it was incumbent upon me to stand up and
say you're doing something terrible to
my family so that's kind of how it
really worked for me and when you're in
a drama department at Carnegie Mellon
University I mean you know at least
three-quarters of the of the people are
gay so it wasn't wasn't unusual for me
I was I was reading about this gay
cancer in the 80s and I had heard about
some people that I had worked with one
gentleman who had died and I said God
papi was young that's weird and then I
started hearing about these other
friends who were sick and they had this
weird disease that nobody seemed to be
able to diagnose and then I started
putting it all together as it was coming
out in the news what was happening and
so I was offered the role to play genie
white in the movie of the week the Ryan
White story which told the story about
this young boy for those who don't know
were too young to know this story who
was a hemophiliac who in order to save
his life had to have a blood plasma
infusion couple times a week and it was
called factor 8 and it kept his blood
clotting otherwise if he banked himself
or hurt himself he would the possibility
was that he could bleed to death and so
his mother Genie was his staunch
supporter and at that time the blood
supply was tainted with the AIDS virus
and so was his factor 8 so Ryan acquired
AIDS and it was the story of his being
told that he was no longer allowed to go
to school because he had AIDS and his
mother Jeannie and he decided to fight
it and he was in fact the courts
overturned the the first ruling and he
was allowed to go to school very
powerful story I desperately wanted to
do that movie I got to do that movie and
I got to know Ryan and Jeannie very well
well one day on the set there was a
woman who was interviewing him from the
local paper in North Carolina and she
said to him so why don't you tell me
what your experience was in Indiana in
Cicero Indiana in Kokomo Indiana they
afterwards first so he could go to
school and he said well it was really
tough and he said sometimes I would be
places and people would spit at me and
call me a and do you know how you
have those moments in your life where
everything just sort of all the pieces
of the puzzle just fall into place
I was so unnerved and upset and I get
upset to this day thinking about it
appalled and shocked and disappointed
and I was like somebody drove a stake
through my heart and I thought these are
my friends who are dying and this young
boy is in the process of dying and this
is historic and we are making this story
about his life and what transpired and
his bravery and his courage and I
started thinking about my friends who
had had to come out at the same time as
they were dying and their families
disowning them and you know discounting
them and not coming to see them and
rejecting them and they're lying in
hospital beds dying and I thought these
are the people who cared for me who I
love and I'm not doing anything I'm
making a movie not enough
not enough so then I began to see that
people like Elizabeth Taylor were the
friending Rock Hudson and I saw that
organizations were springing up to help
this community that was becoming so
powerful and alive with its courage and
its bravery and I watched the lesbian
community say to the gay men look you
guys need help just get out of the way
let us help you and that community
bonded with each other and the
transgender community and the the the
the dancing Queens and the the
magnificence of the events that
everybody was doing and I I said this is
a community that is magnificent and
they're being viciously and I don't even
know the word that I want discounted as
human beings in a way that I found
appalling that this country that says
that it is a country of compassion and
love and Christian values could do this
to my family and to my friends and I was
disappointed in myself for not standing
up and for not saying you can't do this
you can't treat this courageous
magnificent amazing community the way
that you are you can't be a president
and two presidents and not mention the
word AIDS you can't fly over the quilt
display in Washington and leave town
when the community comes to display
their dead
can you really mean
that you will do that what kind of human
being human beings are you and so I saw
it and I saw that it was there was
massive homophobia in the country and I
just I had to talk about it
I couldn't live with myself if I didn't
talk about it so it was for me it wasn't
like I was gonna stand up and be this
you know hero for the gay community
you know the LGBT community here I come
it wasn't like that
it was I can't live with myself if I
don't stand up and I was working with
herb and his partner Jonathan at the
time and and and my husband Robert and I
said to all of him I said I I want to do
this I want to I want to do this I want
to I want to find a way if I can to make
a difference or tell the truth or talk
about it and and and they said and urban
particulars that I can help you do that
that I can help you do and that's how it
happened